et
[Musique]
la délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat consacre un rapport à la situation
des femmes en zone rurale une partie des
travaux est consacré aux violences
conjugales
marie pierre monnier est l'une des huit
rapporteurs plus d'un an après la
clôture le 25 novembre 2019 et grenelle
de lutte contre les violences
la question se pose de savoir si les
territoires ruraux et leurs spécificités
ont été suffisamment pris en compte et
si la dynamique impulsée par le
gouvernement elles suffisantes pour
impacter durablement les politiques de
lutte contre les violences en milieu
rural des femmes résidant en zones
rurales sont moins représentées sur la
ligne des coupes nationales et
lorsqu'elles appellent elles décrivent
des moyens contrôle particulier par
exemple l'interdiction d'utiliser le
véhicule ou le contrôle du kilométrage
malgré tout tout se sait et c'est ce qui
m'a vraiment mais choqués d'un cette
table ronde là c'est le chiffre de 50%
de féminicide en france qui ont lieu
dans les territoires ont alors que c'est
31 % de la population qui habite qu'au
fond ces violences c'est un angle mort
ça n'a pas été assez abordé et la
spécificité des territoires ruraux n'a
pas été prise en compte
entre autres dans les grenelles sa
pointe aussi un manque de moyens pour
les femmes en zone rurale au fond c'est
une double violence
[Musique]
depuis qu'elle a été élue sénatrice de
la drôme en 2014
marie pierre mony reçoit de nombreux
témoignages de victimes de violences un
phénomène dont elle ne soupçonnait pas
l'ampleur sur son territoire
le fait que je me sois mobiliser là
dessus ça a fait que petit à petit j'ai
été identifiés comme occupant de ce
sujet de violences faites aux femmes sur
mon territoire et donc inévitablement
j'ai eu des tas d'appels à l'aide de
certaines cette semaine j'ai eu quatre
contacts quatre femmes que j'avais déjà
rencontré une c'est un peu particulier
c'est une élue qui un jour quand j'ai
rencontré dans sa commune m'a fait
écouter un enregistrement en disant est
ce que ça pour vous ça veut dire que
cette femme est victime de violence
cette femme s'était m
mais j'ai dit bien sûr
la sénatrice rencontre ce jour-là une
victime qui a subi des violences pendant
16 ans sortir du silence dans un village
de 60 habitants a été pour elle une
épreuve c'est vous qui avez fait ça oui
une étape de décision ce que choisit
aujourd'hui pour ma vie à tous le
respect l'amour et tout va bien
voilà
le 8 mars dernier isabelle a pris la
parole en public pour raconter son
histoire
je rentre pas un podcast qui retrace à
ce que vous avez fait le v mars
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler je
savais qu'il y avait un rassemblement
qui avait lieu dans la petite ville à 30
km de chez moi et je savais qu'il y
avait un micro de disponible pour des
prises de paroles ouverte et donc j'ai
écrit un texte titré du tabou sociétal
des violences conjugales et familiales
le 6 janvier 2020 j'ai porté plainte
pour violence conjugale entre l'homme
qui a été mon compagnon pendant 16 ans
et qui est le père de mes trois enfants
ça a été un grand moment pour moi parce
que ça a été témoigné à visage découvert
et en fait après mon dépôt de plainte
j'ai entendu les ouï-dire qui circulent
en milieu rural du genre non mais tu te
rends compte et a porté plainte
comment il va faire pour retrouver une
nouvelle nana non mais tu te rends
compte c'est quand même le père de ces
gamins et là je me suis dit il ya un
vrai problème
il ya eu donc ces années terribles ce
que vous avez réussi à faire à vous
extraire et à essayer de reconstruire
votre vie mais ce que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est non seulement la
façon dont vous en parlait dans vous
allez analyser la situation
quand vous êtes arrivé à vous en sortir
mais aussi comme vous l'avez dit doser
le dire parce que c'est pas toutes les
femmes qui ont été victimes de violence
qui osent aller sur la place publique
6,1 depuis
quand il m'arrive d'aller en ville faire
mes courses
il ya des personnes que je ne connais
absolument pas qu'ils viennent me voir
qui me remercient pour cette prise de
parole voir qui me confient leur
histoire passée ou présente l'histoire
de leur soeur de leur mère de leur
cousine
donc pour moi c c c'est vraiment
embêtant parce que oui tout à fait mais
tout a libéré la parole vous avez
libérer votre parole vous expliquer que
c'est important pour vous mais c'est
important pour toutes les femmes qui
sont encore dans le silence qui sont
parfois encore dans le déni
de plus en plus nous n'aurons plus peur
nous sommes les femmes qui marchent
debout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le village de miscou habite isabelle est
situé au coeur du diois dans le sud de
la drôme où la quasi totalité des
communes ont moins de 1000 habitants
valence ville la plus proche est à 60 km
en ruralité la mobilité c'est vraiment
le sujet parce que on est là on est dans
un endroit magnifique un cadre de vie
exceptionnel mais par contre on est un
peu loin des services publics il faut
avoir une voiture les moyens de se le
payer et ça veut dire qu'on va se
déplacer pour tous pour les courses
comme pour les soins ça veut dire aussi
que si elle veut le porter plainte il
faut qu'elles se déplacent à la
gendarmerie
donc tout ça ça rajoute c'est un peu une
double peine pour les femmes qui sont en
réalité par rapport à d'autres qui sont
en urbain
face au manque de structures c'est le
tissu associatif qui prend le relais
dans la prise en charge des victimes les
femmes nous nous parle par exemple très
souvent soir soit les enfants sont
couchés sans pousser plus propice
souvent à caractère urgent on l'entend
dans la voix et puis elles ont un tel
sentiment de honte qu'elle ne fréquente
plus personne autour d'elle les cas de
violences se multiplient françoise marc
a décidé de co fondé en 2020 une
association d'aidé aux victimes
cette disponibilité ses précieux je
pense pour les femmes parce que souvent
c'est difficile pour elle d'appeler la
saison ça peut se permettre des semaines
voire des mois avant avant qu'elle se
décide
dans la petite ville de 10 aucun lieu de
permet d'accueillir les femmes dans
l'urgence il existe bien des permanences
mensuelles avec un juriste à valence
mais la distance et le fait de devoir
prendre rendez vous décourage beaucoup
de femmes la plupart des femmes qu'on
accompagne
elles sont pas prêtes à aller déposer
plainte c'est une étape lointaine et
hypothétique de leur parcours et à ce
moment là ça sera très bien les juristes
des associations des deux victimes
mais non nous nous relayons les conforte
déjà dans les petits pas qu'elles font
sans aller encore en justice et elles
n'iront peut-être pas c'est pas
indispensable c'est très coûteux d'aller
en justice sur le plan psychosocial et
psychologique donc c'est vraiment elle
qui prennent les décisions
nous on sait que ça va prendre du temps
et on vise l'or en vises leur mieux
mieux être mais immédiat avec un budget
annuel de 200 euros difficile de louer
un local
alors elle reçoit les femmes chez elle
[Applaudissements]
en pleine procédure judiciaire sept
victimes que nous appellerons sahara ne
s'exprimera pas sous sa véritable
identité
ça avance donc il va être entendu là
dans les shows qui dans quelques jours
moi je suis un des performances et on a
discuté
vous étiez encore très très mal vous
étiez encore je pense dans la dépression
mais vous vous étiez comme une terre cpt
a soif est en fait le peu que je disais
ça vous parle
j'avais besoin de dire stop le truc
c'est que c'est ce qui fait hésiter
aussi d'aller porter plainte c'est le
fait de ne pas être entouré le fait
d'être peut-être mal reçue à la
gendarmerie pas cru
il faille se justifier sur des choses
que l'on a vraiment envie que
l'extérieur mais aussi le fait que ça se
sera peut être classée sans suite et ça
en dit mais à quoi bon quand vous avez
besoin de petites d'information et puis
effectivement d'orientation vers des
professionnels sélectionnés mais c'est
vraiment un travail intérieur vous avez
fait c'est des dossiers qu'il touche
plein de choses le problème c'est que
c'est un peu le parcours du combattant
parce que une personne vous renvoie vers
une autre personne c'est bien d'avoir
quelqu'un qui fait le lien avec tout ça
ce que fait votre association
je sais pas si j'aurai la force d'aller
déposer plainte et quand bien même j'y
serai peut-être à l'élément dans les
poches entre guillemets et sans sens
sans rien sans attestation pas préparé
et je pense que ça aurait pas donné
grand chose en zone rurale seulement 12%
des femmes pousse la porte d'une
gendarmerie contre 36% en ville a dit
l'accueil s'est améliorée mais comme
partout les plaintes ont augmenté dans
la drôme avec le confinement lorsqu'une
personne se présente pour déposer
plainte donc elle est reçue ici par le
chargé d'accueil s'il s'agit de
violences conjugales
contrairement à l'an passé où la plainte
s'étaient recueillis ici comme vous
pouvez le voir la confidentialité n'est
pas exceptionnel allez maintenant prise
en charge est accompagné dans un bureau
plus à l'écart ou honte aux procédés son
audition en toute confidentialité
pour lionel gracia cette confidentialité
est primordial en zone rurale il est le
référent violences conjugales de la
brigade et joue un rôle de premier plan
on les installe sur cette chaise dans un
premier temps il ya une phase d'écouté
où elle nous relate les faits d' entre
les gens et des victimes
il pouvait arriver qu'on renvoie chez
elle une femme venue porter plainte sans
certificat médical ou 100 marques de
coups sur le visage des lacunes qui font
partie du passé assure le gendarme c'est
l'investissement refuser dépose plainte
on va faire un renseignement judiciaire
avec rechute dépôt de plainte qu'on va
transmettre au procureur
mais qui peut nous demander de procéder
à l' enquête malgré tout et si la
victime accepte de déposer plainte on
ouvre une enquête
tout simplement on leur conseille
vivement de déposer plainte
aussi parce que le je pense que pour
leur construction
c'est important de pouvoir exercer ses
droits de victime est d'avoir accès aux
droits de la victime
je pense que c'est important lionel
gracia en est convaincu il faut proposer
autre chose qu'un numéro de procédure
pour mieux accompagner ces femmes c'est
primordial d'être formés et de
comprendre la psychologie de ses
victimes
on marche souvent sur des oeufs on
essaye d'établir un lien de confiance de
comprendre pourquoi ils réagissent comme
ça pourquoi elle retourne assez
régulièrement auprès de leurs auteurs
pourquoi parfois les défendre lorsqu'on
intervient elles prennent la défense de
l'auteur alors qu'elle nous demande de
venir intervenir mais voilà ces
personnes qui sont souvent prises et ça
c'est pas évident de le savoir si on
n'est pas formé à ça
ils sont une quarantaine de gendarmes de
tous grades de différentes unités de la
drôme en formation ce jour là l'objectif
est de former tous les gardiens de la
paix du département c'est l'une des
mesures fortes du grenelle contre les
violences conjugales
nous allons passer plus de six heures
ensemble pour une formation à la prise
en compte des violences intra familiales
sujet grave gravissime l'actualité nous
le rappelle tous les jours
quasiment un des féminicides
donner des outils aux gendarmes pour
mieux reconnaître les violences et
comprendre leur impact psychologique il
va mener tombe il taclé ma cuisse si je
ne fais qu à davantage de l'année sera
jamais non il va nous tue c'est pas tous
dupes et des enfants et dans la même
phrase il va me dire je t'aime
personne ne démarre à me regarder moche
et ça c'est le prix vous allez voir que
pour une personne comme ça faire là les
forts parce qu'il s'agit vraiment d'un
effort de venir se confier à un gendarme
pour dire qu'elle est violente et ça
nécessite du courage il faut le
respecter
il faut le prendre en compte dès le
départ et donc votre attitude au moment
de cet accueil de cette première prise
de contacts qu'elle soit à l'unité ou
parfois en intervention sera
déterminante pour la poursuite de l'
enquête
vous devez impérativement avoir la
confiance de cette personne vous êtes
neutre vous êtes là pour traduire des
éléments objectifs aux magistrats pour
lui permettre d'entrer en voie de
condamnation
ça c'est les fondements notre métier
fournir aussi des clés pour améliorer le
recueil de la plainte
et faire en sorte qu'elles aboutissent
bien au parquet car pour les victimes
ce n'est pas évident d'année des preuves
l'audition de la victime est certes très
importante mais le gendarme l'enquêteur
s'attache également à essayer d'obtenir
des témoignages pour corroborer
lorsqu'on est dans un milieu familial
avec des enfants les enfants aussi
seront associés participeront à lenquête
avec des moyens adaptés
vous savez qu'on a des enquêteurs qui
sont formés à la prise en charge est
allé aux auditions de mineurs donc en
fonction de l'âge de la victime
on aura des personnels adapté qui vont
essayer avec des mots simples de
décrypter les situations la difficulté à
préserver l'anonymat en milieu rural
pèse aussi sur la libération de la
parole un obstacle supplémentaire pour
marie qu'il oblige encore aujourd'hui à
ne pas donner son vrai prénom
y'a pas sur le moment où je suis tombée
enceinte
les choses ont commencé à gagner dans le
groupe je savais pas au fait comment
m'en sortir par rapport à un cyclone de
violence qui se répétait moi j'en
pouvais plus au fait ce qui m'a fait
déclencher en fait le départ c'est que
je me disais mais notre enfant il
subissait violence parce qu'en fait
c'est il était témoin des violences et
lorsqu'elles a porté plainte
marie s'est senti plus isolé que jamais
moi j' avais pas vraiment conscience que
ça jusqu'ici mais le milieu rural c'est
le village c'est tout le monde se
connaît et à passer en mauges est
énoncée à plusieurs personnes de mon
entourage qu'on se séparer et que
j'avais en fait subi des violences et
bains ni personne à qui j'en ai parlé
elles n'ont pu adresser la parole j'ai
pu contact avec elle
je pensais qu'en en parlant à des
personnes que je connaissais
au contraire j'allais recevoir un
soutien on allait au contraire peut-être
est tous là pour moi reflète et ça a été
complètement contraire donc ça a été
vraiment extrêmement dur e
une fois que les victimes commencent à
parler il n'y a souvent pas de retour en
arrière et c'est à ce moment là qu'elles
sont le plus en danger
n'oublions pas qu'une femme qui est
victime de violence risque si elle
restée chez elle au moment où elle part
c'est là le plus souvent que ça se passe
ça peut aller jusqu'aux féminicide elle
risque sa vie donc c'est important
justement de pouvoir l'extraire quand
elles ont décidé de franchir le cap et
de et d'arrêter ces violences et donc de
partir de chez elle pour recevoir pas
mal à la permanence c'est compliqué de
trouver un lieu j'en ai même une et qui
m'a appelé à quinze jours qu'ils
savaient plus comment faire les termes
pleurs au téléphone parce que le savez
pas où aller et les places ne sont pas
si nombreuses que ça
neuf maisons de bénévoles offrent un
refuge temporaire aux femmes qui ont
quitté leur domicile
vanessa perez coordonne cette initiative
soutenue par le département votre réseau
et créer de people c'est ça depuis août
2019 du coup la mise en place du réseau
d'accueil ce qu elle est dense et un
accueil qui se fait au sein de sa muse
voilà des parties du vécu sans nuage
effectivement dans l'accueil des femmes
victimes de violence alors soit seul
soit avec leurs enfants
voilà pour les accueillir au moment de
leur départ
on n'a pas effectivement pu développer
d'autres types d'accueil dans
appartenant notamment d'urgence
le grenelle nous annoncer
mille places d'accueil mois concrètement
drôme franchement depuis 2010 neigeux je
ne les vois pas le besoin est toujours
aussi important on entend que c'est
vraiment la grande cause du quinquennat
la cause des femmes mais concrètement
sur le terrain pour le moment les
moyennes on ne les voit pas donc madame
monnier on va aller rencontrer un couple
d'accueillant du réseau d'accueil
citoyens
donc c'est important que le lieu restent
à doni mékong ardossi leur anonymat
voilà pour les protéger mais aussi pour
protéger les femmes qu'ils accueillent
avec les enfants pour paquet
représailles de risques voilà un
concernant l'auteur rejoint je veux lui
mange
[Musique]
merci de nous recevoir
ce couple de retraités accueil des
victimes depuis un an
pour eux les moyens accordés par l'état
ne sont pas à la hauteur lui plusieurs
cas de violences conjugales sinon sur le
village c'est vrai qu'on est on est dans
un lieu assez désertique mais c'est sûr
qu'il ya un déficit en lieux
on en parlait avec vanessa n'est
généralement elles sont pas nombreux
acides et ses citoyens de se prévaloir
tout à fait combien de femmes avec des
enfants notamment accueilli cinq femmes
ah oui déjà 3 qui avait deux enfants et
deux qui n'avait pas d'enfant d'accord
sur quelle durée
il est à la vente alors le minimum
c'était une quinzaine de jours et le
maximum c'était un mois et demi deux
mois je prends un oxymore manque on a
réfléchi aux difficultés parfois les
accueille des femmes victimes de
violence à l'antenne que ce que ça
implique de se retrouver seul dans un
hôtel au moment d'un départ du domicile
et qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait proposer
d'autres une autre à c'est en activant
fait pour accueillir les femmes
une solution d'hébergement qui permet
aux femmes d'être accompagnés dans leur
reconstruction et limite le retour au
domicile avec le conjoint violent
[Musique]
et puis pour le reste de la vie avec
nous elles vivent partage la cuisine se
baladant chambre quand elles ont vu de
se balader à l'organiser moi ça va leur
faire une bonne bouffée d'oxygène plus
isolé encore une fois sorti du silence
marie n'a pas été accompagné dans les
différentes étapes de son parcours
se sentant livrée à elle même elle a
hésité plusieurs fois avant de déposer
plainte
un an après son dossier a été classé
sans suite sans aucune enquête elle a
décidé d'écrire au procureur de la
république pour exprimer son désarroi
cette décision de votre part d'un
classement sans suite sans aucune
enquête a été traumatisante
je me suis sentie nié dans l'existence
du phénomène de violence qui a pourtant
porté atteinte à mes droits les plus
fondamentaux à savoir le respect de mon
intégrité physique
c'est chic intellectuelle et morale
un classement sans suite faute de
preuves matérielles
marie avait pourtant fourni des éléments
dont l'attestation d'un témoin je
souhaitais avoir une reconnaissance et
[Musique]
un espace pour réparer le préjudice
heures qui a été fait reconnaître les
faits
reconnaître ce qui s'est passé c'est
grave c'est répréhensible
pour moi ça ça ça permet juste à
l'auteur des faits de d'être confirmé
dans sa posture de ce que tout est un
peu tout va mieux en fait on peut
continuer à la violence en fait c'est
pas punis
en france 80 % des plaintes pour
violences sont classées sans suite
pour françoise marre c'est bien le signe
que la chaîne pénale est insuffisante
un sujet qui revient fréquemment lors
des réunions avec les autres
intervenants de l'association d'aidé aux
victimes
leur priorité les aider à constituer un
dossier solide car seulement 18 % des
plaintes donne lieu à des investigations
d'autant que dans les campagnes récolter
des preuves est loin d'être évident
comment mourir le dossier des éléments
qui serviront aux femmes à passer le
premier clanwar de quand elles vont
faire un renseignement judiciaire encore
plus une crainte que leur affaire soit
prise au sérieux par le procureur que ça
soit pas classé les éléments de preuve
par exemple même le médecin il hésitera
parce que il est là il à monsieur est il
à madame dans sa classe sa patientèle
beaucoup plus je pense qu'en visionnaire
ou en ville on a nous on n'a pas trop le
choix pour les pour le choix de ne pas
trop le choix des soignants il ya eu les
voisins je souhaite témoigner aussi
quand on a un trou il aime ça c'est
clair
souvent ce salon qu'un des représailles
en fait ce qui ressort de notre de nos
échanges de manière vraiment frappante
c'est la difficulté que ces femmes
même avec notre elle des difficultés
qu'ils ont à réunir les preuves des
témoignages ont ce territoire rural
parce que on ne sait pas les alliances
que les auteurs font avec les voisins
étaient même avec les amis quand c'est
pas la famille il ya quand même beaucoup
d'auteurs qui ne veulent pas se
reconnaître responsable qui joue un jeu
d'alliances pour se démarquer et même
décrédibiliser la famille enfin les
églises et voilà déstabiliser la femme
et la rendre responsable de ce qui se
passe mais là donc ça apprendra c'est
aussi fondamentale interne
une seule solution selon elle pour que
les plaintes aboutissent donner des
moyens à la justice que la france se
dote de tribunaux spécialisés comme en
espagne à peine plus de 10% des femmes
déposent plainte
et parmi celles qui dépose plainte à
peine plus de 12 13% voient leur
agresseur condamné donc ça continue dans
le diois comme ailleurs avec le règne de
l'impunité pour les auteurs nous
croisons les hommes ils sont
récidivistes dans les agressions mais
ils sont tranquilles
en milieu rural comme partout près de
deux ans après le grenelle lancé par le
gouvernement
beaucoup dénoncent des lenteurs et un
manque de financement
alors qu'en france les chiffres ne
bougent pas une femme sur dix est
victime de violences conjugales et une
femme meurt tous les trois jours sous
les coups de son conjoint actuel des
femmes sont victimes de violences donc
il ya urgence à faire quelque chose pour
leur sauver la vie
il faut vraiment s'attaquer à la racine
et travailler pour qu'elle n'ait plus
lieu plus pour qu'on ne se permettent
plus d'être violents vis-à-vis des
femmes et bien c'est reconnaître
qu'elles sont légales des hommes et si
on veut vraiment s'y atteler pour les
supprimer si on veut vraiment en faire
la grande cause du quinquennat est
fausse monnaie les moyennes mais de
travailler en amont c'est à dire c'est
la prévention et c'est l'éducation
c'est la société qu'il faut changer
c'est le regard et la place qu'on donne
aux femmes donc c'est un travail en
profondeur t il faut des moyennes et dès
le plus jeune âge
[Musique]